2000年の皆さん酔っ払ったことありますか
いやあーちゃダメだわかっちゃダメじゃやっぱだったことないと思いますお酒は二十歳
になってからならやっぱだったことないと思うんですけども今回ですねスゴイものを
買ってみました
小さいわーこういう国はこちら fatal ビジョン8これですねー
なんだっけ作れあそうそうちゃんだったこれゴーグルなんですけどなんだこれ飲酒状態
大剣豪グっていうか飲酒してる状態を体験できる防具見やすいですつまりこれさえあれ
ばですね未成年の皆さんこれをかけることによってあの大人の人たちはお爺ちゃんお婆
さんたちはお酒を飲んだらなんかいつも変なことされてふらふらしててちょっと
バカっぽい気がどんな状態なんだっていうのねこれをつけることによって体験すること
が出来ます人種状態体験ゴーグル
これの目的は飲酒により引き起こされる資格の狂い及びそれに伴う平衡感覚の喪失など
の進退能力の低下を背景することができますこういうふうにこれをかけることやって
飲酒の危険性米感じられるらしいですうん僕もお酒弱い
ね結構フラフラするんですけども大抵覚えてないんですよ愛でどういうどういう状況な
のかっていうか覚えてられないんでここがちょっと実際にこれをつけてみようって話
ですよ
うわぁ埋まってやばい
豪雨
これをつけると思うで酔った状態の死角になるらしいで早速ちょっとつけてみましょう
あ
3万円で早速ないそう言ってつけてみましょう行けちょっとつけてみますね
うわーうわーこれぶーぶちゃすがっツルツルする猫チラチラして有効だった容器
坊ちゃんねるうわぁこれは本当にこんな感じではうわぁすっごぃうげー
再現度すごいねちょっと気持ち悪くなりましたねそうね言った時はこんな感じだった気
がするよ
みなさん大変せた気をつける
こんな館ず全然わかんねえなこれたぶんね超よっている状態ですねだいぶ酔っている
ときだとこんな感覚なんだと思います
ちゃんとあるけどやってみます
ブーブー
小倉しか発揮気がするある上げてみてどうだっててあげてみて
じゃんっ
9分
よく歩きますね2位いやじゃありませんじゃんっ
入ってるわけでこれつけているだけどめっちゃくちゃ本当に視界が悪くてものファンク
とわからないですよ
今回はそのよっだ泥制して状態の自分のさらに上に行くために国がのファニ
キャン回開店してからこれをつけるとどうだってことかもう泥酔の上ですからその逃げ
たっちゃうことができない感覚に達するところですよね社会もあります
pas
ジャックポットのマジック程度から始めますけどそう
うわぁあああっっっ
ああああああ
rar
me
hatake a
me あった
皆さん
お酒には気をつけましょう the あっ